a Silverado Ranch resident reaching out
to 8 news now after he says an old
Century Link Box in his yard is a danger
to his neighborhood and he wants it
fixed before he says anyone gets
seriously hurt he lives on Corona run
Avenue near Silverado Ranch and Pollock
drive as Victoria Saha reports the
homeowner says his complaints have not
yet been addressed
imagine having to watch her every step
around your own front yard while an old
CenturyLink box is causing concern for a
property owner after he says he almost
fell right through it we're going to
take care of it that is what David
rounds says he keeps hearing from
CenturyLink a phone and internet company
now bought by lumen in May rounds found
out the hard way The Rusted box placed
by the company in his front yard is
unstable I actually stepped down on this
part right here and put my whole heel
through it like this he says since then
he has made numerous calls to the
company each time we get a hold of him
they say someone comes out looks at it
spray paints it again and says you know
it'll be done in a couple weeks and
nothing's ever happened since the back
and forth issue has been going on for
four months by the time rounds contacted
us we reached out to the company to see
what the delay was they sent me this
saying in part every project is
important to us and we want to get this
done as quickly as possible we are
waiting on a permit from Clark County to
do the work that's how loose this stuff
is until the work actually happens
rounds is scared the spray paint and the
cones are on the box won't be enough we
have a lot of kids in the neighborhood a
lot of dogs come out here it's a danger
to my family the homeowner says he's so
frustr rated he might end up taking
gravel and filling the hole himself just
to keep pets and kids in the
neighborhood safe in Silverado Ranch
Victoria saham 8 News Now
well the company tells Victoria the
damage came from years of water that
passed over the box now we also asked
the company when exactly they filed for
the work permit but they haven't
responded